corri ma noi non abbiamo paura quindi
possiamo andare anche di qua
Ah è tipo granny
Forse è meglio se io dico corri corri
corri
Stef oggi nuovissima Escape Room paurosa
vi ricordate di Miss anitron la
professoressa robot da cui siamo venuti
a scappare Ebbene è tornata ed è tipo
sua figlia ed è Non mi ricordo come si
chiama comunque il gioco si chiama
Piccola Cucina inquietante oh oh oh
spaventoso eh vedete un bel mi piace
Mettetevi comodi vieni stavo subito
Eccola qua la vedete come gira la testa
che è pronta Ah lì okay non pensare a
mangiare perché non penso che riuscirai
a mangiare qua vediamo
magari troviamo qualcosa eh È tutto buio
qua dice di seguire questa freccia Ok
comunque avete visto di nuovo gli
orecchini orecchini del giorno sono le
farfalle blu scrivete nei commenti foto
da 1 a 10 agli orecchini del giorno
farfalle Allora dai sì devi buttarti giù
ci sono dei laser e credo che bisogna
morire Ok In che senso mi ha già preso
ovviamente primo sfracellamento Vitale
quanti sfracellamenti avrà Vitale Dai ok
Abbiamo anche la torcia vedi davvero
illuminare vediamo
ancora non si è visto il cattivo
l'animatore bravissimo
andate via da qua
sta arrivando aiuto Ok scappa corri ma
noi non abbiamo paura quindi possiamo
andare anche di qua
Eccolo qua l'ho vista non vedo non vedo
non vedo l'ora
Oh io mi sono salvato eh aiuto aiuto
aiuto aiuto aiuto
Dai dai Ceci
Uffa dai devi correre Bravo corri corri
corri corri corri corri
Vai vai Segui sempre le frecce Aiutatemi
aiutatemi aiuto
aiuto!ahahahah Ok Ciao raga Sono dietro
di te bravissimo allora E ora come
sempre nelle fogne in ogni Hobby che
facciamo finiamo nelle pugliese non lo
so perché tutti mettono le foglie Ah
Vitale è caduto No non mi ricordo Ah ok
per fortuna
non ci sarebbe stato cibo no Ehi Ma
sbaglio siamo dei nani in questo un
pochino così
siamo diventati dei bambini io intanto
vado avanti devo prendere la verità Vai
corri corri corri corri corri corri
corri corri mi dice che non credo che
prenderà il baggiù giusto Oh c'è
qualcuno qui Ti fermerai distratto dal
cibo
[Musica]
sta dicendo dove sei Puoi fidarti di me
Chi è certo come no allora
è un po' pericoloso qui Dobbiamo saltare
è diventato una sorta di Mission
Impossible
mattonelle però nel frattempo ci sono
anche i laser quindi
prova a passare sotto Ecco perché siamo
più bassi
Anche a me ha preso ok È difficile
questa parte comunque eh Allora piano
con calma dobbiamo riuscire a superare
tutto con calma
almeno non sei stato preso da quel
mostro come si chiama lei si chiama Boh
matta
con questo è difficile no Come ha fatto
a prendermi sei riuscita e li devi fare
un mini saltino in modo da non prendere
il laser ma è molto difficile
perde bisogna essere veloci perché
altrimenti
oh no dove sono finito
non mi ha fatto iniziare da capo non so
perché Eh ma che dici
Non lo so che cosa è successo
Allora qua bisogna passare sotto Ma
perché io riesco
devi saltare poco qua Ma come non
ho neanche un attimo
Qualcosa mi dice che questo è molto
difficile quindi ci impiegheremo un bel
po' che abbiamo fatto credo che ci
impiegheremo un bel po' Ok
concentrazione
mi piace per colpa mia
Ok ragazzi dopo 10.000 tentativi di
morte cioè no tentativi di sopravvivenza
Fabio morte L'Italia è riuscita come ora
Manco solo io dai loro cosa hai fatto
qua hai saltato sei passato sotto e No
ho saltato le ho saltato di tutti
è un po' complesso questo devi fare un
salto un saltino per saltare dall'altra
parte della mattonella vai Ci sei quasi
finito No non ci credo
difficilissima questa parte e chissà se
forse ora sarà ancora più difficile eh
che facciamo
posto strano che cosa sono questi
sembrano tipo degli spuntoni Eh Che
succede e non toccarli no no no no no
non li sto tocca ah ah che rotola
e come si farà evita quei cosi ok Forse
bisogna saltare piano piano piano piano
piano piano e infatti sei proprio andato
sopra
Allora aspettiamo Vitale ma io non so
dove devo andare qui devi andare qua
dove sono io
la tua barra della vita però è molto
bassa Sì ok La freccia è qua attento non
cadere giù no
alla fine dovremmo affrontare Miss cuoca
cattiva
Si prega di attendere l'arrivo
dell'ascensore
molto gentile
ma non arriva l'ascensore Eccolo eccolo
sta scendendo
ok Dove ci porterà adesso credo
[Musica]
Sì sei incastrato
però la mia vita sta crescendo dalla
rossa è diventata gialla
In che senso vuoi nasconderti più dici
corri corri corri ti consiglio di
correre corri corri corri corri corri
corri
c'è Vabbè io ho corso comunque
ci sei
capito
Torna qua dice
ha una voce inquietantissima più di
quella di granny perché è un po'
Metallica Che cosa sono questi laser
Verdi Ah quindi qui laser per tutti
sfracello
sono avanti Vabbè io vado a prendere in
Belgio Ciao Anita Ciao ciao
Sì sì certo come me Ah questi ti portano
indietro
Cioè ah ah vita però l'anno No non puoi
andare avanti Quindi dietro
ce l'ho fatta sono avanti
Vitale lo prenderò io il badge perfetto
buoni pure nei confronti
cattiva
dai Godiamoci lo spettacolo vediamo
Vitale che cade di nuovo ci impiegherò
molto ancora questa volta io credo che
ci impiegherò tanto tempo
Okay
nei sotterranei in cui il pavimento è
lavato fate i salti un po' strani In che
senso non lo so non mi sono incastrato
mi sono incastrato abbiamo le gambe più
cortesemente vero
No no
Che succede Sono caduto nella lava no sì
siamo forse già riusciti a scappare Non
lo prendere prima il peggio però è
troppo bello per essere vero che siamo
già riusciti a scappare ma qualcosa mi
dice che dovremmo ancora affrontare miss
oh hahaha non sappiamo come si chiama
perché non c'è scritto Miss Wow
lei è qui credo eh credo sia qui forse è
meglio Siri
corri corri
Uffa che cosa dobbiamo fare quindi è lì
è ancora lì devi correre devi correre
devi correre
non mi dire
no non ci crede hai preso in mezzo prima
di me eh guarda qui Ah ah ah ci credo No
ce l'ho fatta lo sapevo Aspetta che mi
sbatto il 5 da solo Evviva Ho vinto io
ah ah dobbiamo fare un'altra t-room
perchè devo vincere io questa volta
ho vinto io posso scegliere io qual è la
prossima Hobby a cui giocare ho scelto
il ristorante così
Guardate dove siamo arrivati È proprio
il posto per Vitale questo siamo nello
specifico in un ristorante stile
americano vedete Ma come hai fatto già
il gelato Visto il liquido per terra lì
dovevo non dovevo fare Aiuto aiuto che
sta combinando stiamo ancora
piccolissimi Non so perché comunque
altrimenti ci nei commenti siete voi il
ristorante americano un ristorante stile
americano come questo Noi ci siamo stati
e Adoro le patatine fritte
Eccola Infatti Eccole qua le vedete
giganti queste patatine fritte
ancora meglio Oh no ma perché mi saltano
i capelli
l'obiettivo di questa nuova Escape Room
del ristorante e prendere il mezzo prima
di Vitale
Speriamo che Vitale venga distratto da
tutto questo cibo ma anche il pesce
sciroppo d'acero Ah ah ah sì guarda
questi qua sono più scuro sono
cioccolato No non aspetto proprio niente
Ciao Non lo so perché ma ti ho visto Il
Gigante ma avete visto anche voi è
diventato il gigante per un momento il
personaggio di Vitale boom
boom Wow Wow
ci sono anche i waffle devo dire che sta
venendo fame anche a me questo
pallino di gelato allora Natale mi ha
superato sono inciampato sulla Palli di
cioccolato di qua dove si va di qua Sì
ho superato Vitale Adesso vado verso la
macchina dei pop corn No ho sbagliato
È proprio strapieno di cibo Cioè sta
venendo fame anche a me non immagino
abitare
ho cancellato di nuovo non ce la faccio
e qua c'è un tipo che sta mangiando la
sua saliva Cioè sta mangiando un panino
poi è riuscita tipo questa strana cosa
che provo e penso che noi dobbiamo
evitare la sua saliva ed evitare di
essere mangiati lì capito
sicuramente
Ehi Come hai fatto a superarmi subito Ah
ecco infatti sei molto Cioè ma che que
possiamo evitare la saliva di questo
Tu mi stavi dicendo che praticamente lui
ci mangerà
quindi una volta che ci mangiamo
dobbiamo uscire
da quella parte
Oh no sì mi ha appena mangiato vedo
tutti i denti qua eh
nuvola dovevi evitare Dai presto Arriva
non è stato mangiato Anch'io non vedo
l'ora di vedere quando finirà in quella
parte di tutti che non mi piace quella
parte lì Uffa
cadiamo nella gola Oh
pronto
Guarda guarda
guardato tutto intero eh Eh sì non ha
masticato Ma perché io sono morta
perfetto È il momento di scappare Allora
mi serviva indietro Tu non sei morto
Ah ecco bisognava cadere qua Hahaha ora
Sì certo Guarda sono già incinta Ciao In
che parte del corpo siamo qua Non lo so
Ehi Ma come hai fatto a salire così
velocemente
Oh non lo sapevo che abbiamo
non lo sapevo che abbiamo una scacchiera
nel nostro corpo
Sì arriverò prima
Vedremo vedremo
chi arriverà prima
risposta arriverà prima Tosi ultimo
passaggio sono qui tanto prima o poi
cadrai neanche tu no Come no
[Musica]
Sei caduta No non mi dire che siamo
davvero già arrivati in quella parte lì
siamo in quella parte lì
siamo ancora a delle ossa come ho fatto
sta progermilarmi
ho trovato un trucchetto bisogna stare
attenti
l'avevo capito perché mi sono
sfracellato perché ho fatto un salto
troppo corto io Grazie a voi solo il
trucchetto anch'io infatti stavo
controllando proprio quello no mmm
dovrebbe essere questa
Ehi e no Ah ha funzionato il trucchetto
Anche io ho fatto quella Ma niente forse
gli sviluppatori ce ne sono accorti
papà
solo che tu non mi volevi credere Oh No
eh aspetta così forse ora posso passare
qua sopra Ehi e posso prendere il pezzo
prima di te No ragazzi
giusto vediamo dove sarà il peggio forse
sarà sopra
andiamo a prendere non ci credo
Arriverò prima io no
[Musica]
Ok allora il primo è questo puoi vedere
io
ma tu
non lo so che cosa è successo sei
diventato tipo il personaggio
Non lo so Secondo voi che cosa è
successo a vedere com'è possibile cioè
bag Ah sono ritornato in me stesso Forse
questo
[Musica]
[Risate]
pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa
pa pa pa pa Ok Ragazzi
abbiamo dovuto abbiamo avuto problemi di
connessione e abbiamo dovuto rifare
l'escape Room tutta da capo quindi
lasciate un mi piace di conforto e ora
finalmente possiamo continuare Se
andiamo su un'altra sfida
Vitale non so dove sia finito
Sembra che hai mangiato un po' troppo
sembri un po' sgrassato no ho messo due
pantaloni perché ce l'avevo bucati con
gli altri
guardateli Roma e questi cosa sono figo
Uh ho capito ah ah ah tanto tutti
sposelli qui dai Adesso c'è la tua parte
preferita non riconosco dal colore ah ah
ah posso ricominciare tutto da capo eh
Ma che dici ogni tanto c'è in questo bug
e non lo so perché Ok andiamo qua nella
parte preferita di vita blu e poi sapete
che
cos'è questa queste cose
mi devo far prendere quel che schifo che
schifo
No Anita sopravantissimo Ehi ma io sono
super indietro Mi dispiace per te Io sto
andando a mangiarmi le patatine fritte
nella lavatrice
non mi devo far distrarre dalle patatine
fritte
Vitale è ancora dentro quel tipo
aiuto Il cane è arrivato nella parte sua
preferita
che schifo che schifo che schifo ah ah
ma tanto ma sono scemo avanti Oh no mi
sta raggiungendo Ehi ma eh quando ha
fatto morire subito ok ho capito No ma
insomma ma che cosa devo fare quando mi
sfracello mi porta indietro di un paio
di livelli ok Finalmente ci sto
riuscendo qua qua Devo prendere il badge
devo prendere il badge prima di Vitale
Ci siamo quasi soddisferemo gli mancano
pochissimi livelli evitare è ancora
indietro Quindi vuol dire che questa
volta vincerò io forse io sono rimasto
bloccato qui ogni volta distrarre troppo
da tutte queste cibo molto rimango
volevo un ritorno indietro in quella
parte brutta Marrone Ah ah ah
maledizione del marrone questa volta
cosa c'entra questo garage nella cucina
non lo so Non mi dire che ci sei
riuscita siamo vicini al Belgio Qualcosa
mi dice che stiamo vicino a Belgio no
Guardate sono uscita fuori dal
ristorante questa era la porta no no no
no che mi guardano Ehi datemi il peggio
subito
no ce l'ho fatta ce l'ha preso il Belgio
Ma tu sei ancora in quella parte Marrone
Io sono rimasto bloccato lì non riesco
andare avanti e questi che sono dice Ehi
Vai a provare i miei altri Hobby Dai
magari nei prossimi episodi proviamo gli
altri dove avete lasciato un bel mi
piace Ora vi lasciamo Qua quattro
caselline su cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video su quella che
preferite eh Buona visione Ciao